tu crois pas que dans l'opinion
française aujourd'hui une adhésion à
cette idée de deux blocs qui c'est qui
qui s'opposent entre les deux offres
alternatives et unique
quand on voit le nombre d'abstentions de
personnes qui disent potentiellement
s'abstenir et en même temps le nombre de
personnes qui disent ne pas vouloir du
duel macron le pen c'est bien la preuve
que certes du ls exister dans le débat
politique mais que les français n'en
veulent pas et que donc un espace en
tout cas pour une offre alternative est
ce qu'il a le temps d'émerger c'est un
autre sujet mais je pense que le ce duel
ne suscite pas un enthousiasme fou des
français et c'est d'ailleurs en partie
ce qui pourrait d'ailleurs faire
l'élection de marine le pen c'est
l'abstention si beaucoup de gens ne vont
pas voter ni au premier ni au second
tour et on voit dans les derniers
sondages aussi qu'une partie des
électeurs de gauche par exemple pourrait
s'abstenir au second tour dans un duel
macro le pen c'est aussi un facteur qui
est favorable paradoxalement à la
victoire du rassemblement national
[Musique]